this is not some DVD floating in space
it's a mega structure that might One Day
become Humanity's home
[Music]
the Earth might not remain habitable
forever
it could get engulfed by a massive solar
flare
or become too hot due to climate change
or have all its life wiped out by one
enormous asteroid
what if I told you we could outlive all
these disasters and that we could do
that by building a space megastructure
Bigger Than The Sun itself
just how big would we have to make it
and What would life be like on a
structure like that
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could build an Alderson
disc
why would we colonize other currently
uninhabitable planets if we could
hypothetically build a habitat of Our
Own
something that would host many billions
of future humans without ever running
out of space
it does look like a DVD doesn't it
only it has the mass of 3 000 Suns
the reason why we'd need our Alderson
disc to have such a huge mass is gravity
all objects with mass are
gravitationally drawn to each other
and objects with a greater mass have a
greater gravitational pull
for the Alderson disc to be stable
enough to host life we'd need it to have
a stronger pull than the sun does
that's where it gets tricky because the
sun is the most massive object in our
solar system accounting for 99.8 percent
of its total mass
to have enough material to outweigh the
sun we'd have to get it by breaking down
every planet Moon and asteroid in a
radius of hundreds of light years around
us
or we could give our Alderson disc
artificial gravity
this type of gravity isn't caused by
attraction but by acceleration or
centrifugal force in other words we'd
have to spin our disc fast enough that
it doesn't collapse into a donut or get
swallowed by the Sun
but since we haven't really figured out
artificial gravity yet
let's stick with the first option and
make our Alderson disc very very massive
241 million kilometers wide
that would make it stretch past the
orbit of Mars
it would also be several thousand
kilometers or miles thick
and would have a surface area equivalent
to over 1 billion Earths
just imagine how many billions of humans
could live on it
ah but not so fast
our Alderson disc wouldn't be habitable
everywhere
and before I explain that let me talk
about the Sun for a moment
our son would be sitting stationary in
the hole at the center of the disc
and because of this our disc would have
no day and night cycle
only a never-ending Twilight
but since our disc would have a bigger
mass and a stronger gravitational pull
there's a chance that the sun would
wobble up and down
that would somewhat solve our day and
night problem but it could also increase
the possibility of colliding with our
star
before we get to the next episode I just
want to take a moment to tell you about
an amazing product we've been working
with called Opus clip you know we run
multiple YouTube channels here at under
known and with those big YouTube
channels well shorts are a big part of
what makes them great they're amazing
ways to connect with our fans and spread
more educational content but making the
shorts can be pretty tough time
consuming you know that's where Opus
clip comes in we've been using it here
at under known to make viral shorts
incredibly fast and effectively it uses
this really cool curation model to
analyze and pick out the best parts of
our video and then seamlessly rearrange
them into shorts that can stand on their
own it's like taking our favorite parts
of each video and cutting them into
bite-sized pieces that you can all enjoy
and what's even better if you're a
Creator trying to get into short form
content well Opus clip is for you you
can try it free by going to Opus dot Pro
Link in the description
we might need to install gamma ray
lasers to have more control over the
sun's wobbling
and still our disc shaped world would
need way more things to become suitable
for us to live on it
one of the most important things is an
atmosphere
on Earth the atmosphere protects us from
harmful ultraviolet radiation it reduces
temperature extremes
and it creates pressure that allows
liquid water to exist
we'd need an atmosphere to do all the
same things for our Alderson disk and to
keep the Sun from stealing it we'd need
to build a wall around the disc's inner
Edge
unlike Earth the Alderson disc wouldn't
have liquid metal in its core to give it
a magnetosphere
a magnetic field is important because it
keeps the solar wind from stripping off
the atmosphere
without it the solar wind would erode
the part of the Alderson disc closer to
the Sun
this could make the entire structure
unstable and possibly destroy it
altogether
[Music]
once we figure out how to make the
atmosphere and magnetic field
we could bring in water
we'd make holes in the disc that would
allow for oceans
because of the way gravity would work on
our Alderson disk the water could be
suspended
the oceans on the disc shaped structure
would literally be bottomless
for the same gravitational reasons
humans would be able to live on both the
top and the bottom side of the disk for
those living on the bottom side it
wouldn't feel as if they were walking
upside down
it would be just normal on each side
[Music]
but of course this space megastructure
could have some flaws
because of the disc's enormous Mass its
gravity might make it collapse into a
gigantic Torus
or even worse a black hole
then there are asteroids
even though we used up all the nearby
asteroids to form our Alderson disc in
the first place
there's no guarantee new Interstellar
space rocks wouldn't come and bombard
our Discworld
and not just asteroids but rogue planets
as well
even the slightest hit could destabilize
the disc and plunge it right into the
sun
speaking of the sun remember I said that
not all of the Alderson disc would be
habitable
that's because the sun wouldn't be
heating it evenly
the inner side of the disc would be very
hard
to withstand the tremendous heat we'd
have to give our disc a heat shield just
like the one we developed for the Parker
solar probe
the outer edges of the disc would be
freezing cold
but the middle band of the structure
would be just perfect for life
although there would be a lot of unused
space
the habitable area would still be 50
million times larger than the entire
surface of Earth
Rockets are incredibly powerful you can
launch yourself into orbit fly the moon
and soon enough travel to Mars but to go
beyond our solar system yay you're going
to need something else
solar sails
how exactly would sales work out in
space
how long would it take you to travel to
the edge of the solar system
and why could this journey end with your
slow and lonely demise
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you sailed the Galaxy on solar
winds
to launch a spaceship you need a rocket
to push you up into the sky
that push is called thrust
being launched from Earth with the power
of a rocket gives a spacecraft most of
its momentum after this you'd need more
fuel to change your speed or course
but there are no gas stations out there
in space for you to refuel and that
means you can only go as far as your
fuel takes you
see more fuel means more weight in in
space your reserves are limited
in other words it would be really hard
to get to your Interstellar destination
with rockets alone
but all of that is about to change
All Aboard you're set to sail across the
Galaxy
on Earth sales have been moving boats
around the globe for centuries they work
without any fuel only the power of wind
but out in space there are no air
particles moving around so you'd need to
harness a different kind of wind
solar winds carry charged particles
ejected by the Sun
and these particles fly across the solar
system at a blisteringly fast 1.6
million kilometers per hour
but with a special type of sale you
could take advantage of that power to
get yourself across the solar system and
beyond
and no those special sails wouldn't look
much like the sales you're familiar with
are you ready to have your mind blown
this is the contraption that could take
you across the Galaxy it's called
electric sales or e-sales
they're kind of like an umbrella without
fabric only these ribs would be made of
electrically charged aluminum wires and
they can be as long as 20 kilometers
while also being no thicker than about
half of one strand of hair upon your
head now all you'd need is the solar
wind and you could sail across the deep
dark sea of outer space
wait wait wait wait
um there's one catch you see you'd still
need chemical Rockets to launch you off
into space to begin with
that's because electric sales don't work
within Earth's magnetosphere
the magnetosphere is the area around the
planet that's under the influence of its
magnetic field
it's up to 10 times larger than Earth
itself and to escape it you'd need a
little boost from the old school Rockets
or you could build a Spaceport around
Earth
it would have to be far enough so that
the planet's magnetic field doesn't
reach it
but you know that would get too
expensive and take too long to construct
and we want to send you on this journey
right now
so you'd launch your ship from Earth and
out of the magnetosphere's limits
from there it would be smooth sailing
with a 1 000 kilogram spacecraft like
yours you'd have about 100 wires to
catch solar wind particles you'd be a
Pioneer voyaging through space with this
fantastic new technology
after one year of sailing you'd reach a
speed of at least 30 kilometers per
second
and you might even go as fast as 150
kilometers per second yeah and that's
really fast faster than Voyager 1 the
fastest space probe humans have ever
sent off world
the Voyager 1 probe is hurtling through
space at about 17 kilometers per second
after spending three years getting past
Mars Jupiter Saturn and Uranus you'd end
up beyond the orbit of Neptune you'd
navigate by simply changing the voltage
levels on different wires of your
electric sails
well you'd still have to be a
navigational genius to sail safely
especially when you get closer to the
outer edges of the solar system
here you have to pass through the Kuiper
belt
this area is filled with icy comets and
if you're not careful these comets will
do some Hefty damage to your electric
sales
yeah your Interstellar trip might end
before you even get out of our planetary
neighborhood
after that you've still got a long way
to go to the very end of the solar
system the heliopause it's four times
further away from the Sun than Neptune
so fasten your seat belts and power
through a pretty uneventful view for
about 10 more years
yeah I know I know you'd prefer a view
of Jupiter or a Uranus instead but hey
it's almost time to explore worlds
you've never seen
oh I just remembered I was supposed to
tell you something important
yeah you know how your electric sales
need solar winds to sail
well uh now you'd be the furthest from
the Sun you've ever been and that means
there won't be as many solar particles
pushing your spaceship forward
your sailing might just come to a
complete stop leaving you stuck forever
in the outskirts of the solar system
cold lonely and hopeless
yeah I'm not gonna lie this could be how
your days come to an end
so while you still have some life left
in your sales you'll need to navigate to
another star
if I were you I'd head to the Alpha
Centauri star system
it's the closest one around and it has
not one but three stars
now you should also know that not all
stars are equal in providing you the
powerful solar winds you so desperately
need
passing by a red dwarf star like Alpha
Centauri C also known as Proxima
Centauri you'd experience luminosities
that could be anywhere from one tenth to
one ten thousandth as strong as our own
Sun
but despite this you might be able to
gain enough accelerating power to reach
super high speeds once again
and all this without any chemical fuel
yeah going green is the cool new thing
everyone's talking about
that's no moon
it's a space station the enormous Planet
killing kind designed for only one thing
to bring order to the Galaxy
it's Star Wars Imperial super weapon the
Death Star
what would it take to build a star like
this
where would we assemble the universe's
biggest weapon of mass destruction
and what unfortunate Planet would be the
first Target for our test firing
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could build the Death Star
I've got a bad feeling about this
but it took the Empire 19 years to build
their first Death Star so we better get
started
it's unclear exactly how big the ds-1
orbital battle station was estimates
vary between 120 kilometers and 160
kilometers in diameter
that's substantially smaller than say
our moon but compared to some of the
smallest moons in the solar system it's
enormous
and we'd only need one thing to build it
money
lots of money
big projects cost big money
in this case we're talking
852 quadrillion dollars
852 with 15 zeros
and that's only the cost of construction
once the Death Star is ready keeping it
up and running wouldn't be any cheaper
weapon or not this space station would
require 1.7 million staff to run the
station's retail shops and Troop
cafeterias
add 25 984 Stormtroopers and 342 953
Imperial Navy soldiers
and you'll get 2 million 68
937 people living aboard the Death Star
if each person on the Death Star created
1.13 kilograms of waste every day it
would cost 564 925 daily not to turn the
Death Star into a landfill
that doesn't include people who fell
into a trash compactor and weren't able
to blast their way out
the daily electricity bill would add up
to 52 billion dollars
274 thousand dollars to feed the crew
with another twenty thousand four
hundred dollars to supply tea or coffee
two hundred and thirty three thousand
for one cycle of laundry
you wouldn't expect your Troopers to run
around with dirty underwear right
the total for keeping the Death Star
operational would amount to 7.8
octillion dollars every day
that's more money than we currently have
here on Earth and it doesn't include the
cost of a single blast of super laser
that would be an additional eight
octillion dollars
still feel like firing lasers into
planets
okay then let's talk about how you could
build the Death Star
you already know it would come with the
price tag of 852 quadrillion dollars but
where would you start assembling this
super weapon
first you'd need a hyper matter reactor
core
let's not go into the specifics of how
such a reactor would work and we'll just
assume that you already have one
you'd build four reactor shafts all
joined along the Equator and a large
column running from top to bottom
this column would help to distribute
power and also act as a station
stabilizer
this Mega project would require a lot of
Steel
by some calculations the Earth has
enough iron in its core to provide for 2
million death stars
but you wouldn't want to sacrifice our
planet for an army of deadly weapons
would you
even if you took only the amount of iron
needed for one Death Star it would take
over eight hundred and thirty thousand
years to produce enough steel so you
could begin Construction
and it would take millions of rocket
launches to get the steel where it
needed to go
by the time the Death Star was finished
this might make our atmosphere so
polluted that we'd be forced to move
away from Earth to another planet
and where would we build the Death Star
anyway
we can't get too far from our planet but
you definitely don't want that thing in
Earth's low orbit
there's too much of a chance of it
falling down to earth
you could start building outside of the
Earth's atmosphere just make sure to not
accidentally blast our planet with the
super laser
speaking of the blast well in reality
light doesn't behave that way
instead it would keep moving in whatever
Direction it was fired
sorry about the mess
by the way destroying an earth-sized
Planet would require a lot of power
you'd need to spend a week collecting
all of the sun's energy before you could
fire up the Death Star
and don't stand anywhere close to the
beam at the moment of the blast
so much energy right next to you even
when not aimed directly at you
would cause you to evaporate in a matter
of seconds
then there's the recoil
the third law of motion teaches us that
every action has an equal and opposite
reaction
that means if you packed a big enough
punch to destroy a planet using the
sun's energy
it would send the Death Star in the
opposite direction at a speed of 77
kilometers per second
that's unless you had an anti-matter
device aboard the Death Star
foreign
is matter but with its electrical charge
reversed
when antimatter meets matter the two
destroy one another
that's why you'd need only
0.00002 percent of the targeted planet's
mass in antimatter to turn that planet
into space debris
in this case The Recoil would be almost
unnoticeable
but you'd better not aim that death star
at any planets in the Solar System
there's a better application for this
weapon
it could be used to vaporize any
asteroids that could be a risk for our
planet
although a giant death orb might be a
little overqualified for the task
at least when an Interstellar asteroid
is hurtling in our Direction we'd be
ready to knock it out before it destroys
us
it's called a bad feeling about it
the Earth may not be our home forever
eventually we may have to leave
What If instead of finding a potentially
habitable exoplanet light years away we
stayed in our solar system and built a
habitat so enormous we could never
overpopulate it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we built a ring World in space
imagine you lived on a ring with a
radius of 150 million kilometers
encircling the Sun a gigantic artificial
world with its own gravity ecosystem and
atmosphere big enough for trillions of
humans to call home
you'd live on an enormous landmass on
the inner side of the Ring the outer
shell would protect you and all those
trillions of people from the hazards of
outer space
how does that sound yeah great problem
is assembling such a thing suspended out
in the solar system wouldn't be easy
you couldn't just pull the Earth apart
and have an army of robots reassemble it
into a ring world
among the many problems you'd run into
your first would be finding the material
the International Space Station roaming
the Earth's lower orbit right now weighs
about 420 tons
something like a ring world would tip
the scales at no less than a million
tons where would we find all this
material
I know some places the Kuiper belt
beyond the orbit of Neptune would do
just fine this ring of icy body
stretches out for almost 3 billion
kilometers
some astronomers think the Kuiper belt
would have enough material for this
project but it's hard to tell exactly
how much we'd need to construct a thing
like this
we might have to sacrifice all the
planets moons and asteroids in the solar
system
a ring world and the sun would be the
only things left
if we could manage to gather and
transport all the material available
then construction would begin
it would take a lot of physical labor an
army of robots and maybe hundreds of
generations to realize that our
structure was not stable enough
because the megastructure would turn out
so enormous it would break any known
molecular bonds
we'd have to find a way to make use of
one of the fundamental forces of nature
the strong nuclear force of all forces
it's the grippiest it bonds material on
the scale of atomic nucleus so that
nothing can break it apart or maybe we'd
come up with a new super strong material
altogether
but until we figure that out every
Interstellar body passing through our
solar system would be a threat to our
megastructure
the next thing we'd have to worry about
is gravity and that part is pretty easy
we just have to spin the Ring World at
nearly 2 million kilometers per hour I
know that's really fast we'd have to
build up that speed over time luckily
maintaining it in the frictionless
environment of space wouldn't be too
hard yeah
such rotation would generate centrifugal
force and that in turn would create an
artificial gravity equal to the one we
have here on Earth
with gravity solved we bring in the
atmosphere and start populating the ring
world
for the inhabitants of the megastructure
it would always be daytime unless we
could create a day and night cycle with
extra panels inside the ring
but for all the epicness of the world we
just created it wouldn't be stable
a single asteroid strike could cause the
structure to drift closer to the Sun a
hole punched through the ring could let
all our atmosphere out and a massive
solar storm don't even get me started on
that one
one failure inside the ring could Doom
the entire structure together with its
inhabitants
it's just too risky to build it around
the sun we might have better luck with a
huge ring space station in the Earth's
orbit
what if we could engineer a gigantic
Mega structure capable of harvesting
every bit of the sun's energy something
known as a Dyson Sphere
how long would it take to construct this
Mega shell where would we find all the
materials needed and what can we do with
the structure once we finally built it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could build a Dyson Sphere
around the Sun
the idea of a Dyson Sphere was well
stolen from Aliens in 1960
astrophysicist Freeman Dyson theorized
another civilization that found a way to
meet their ever-increasing energy and
space demands they rearranged their
solar system this hypothetical Advanced
civilization built a hollow sphere
around their own sun and provided
themselves with an incredible amount of
energy and habitable real estate
but what about us how would we go about
building this space level structure
theoretically if we built a Dyson Sphere
we'd have access to a colossal 400
septillion watts of solar energy
that's a trillion times more power than
our entire civilization consumes today
the problem is no known material is
strong enough to handle all the space
radiation and even if we created one in
very large quantities a tiny
gravitational pull towards the sun would
make our solid Sphere uninhabitable not
to mention that it would be totally
unstable every meteor strike would push
a part of the sphere towards the star
but all these issues can be solved with
a simple adjustment
instead of building a solid Dyson Sphere
we could build a Dyson swarm a myriad of
solar collectors with their individual
orbits around the Sun
let's start with a small station one
that's able to provide the energy needed
for this whole construction project
we'd begin on Mercury it would become
our space mine for the iron and oxygen
we'd need
from those elements we'd make highly
reflective solar collectors
the giant mirrors would reflect light
into a small solar power plant
from there it would beam the energy to
where we need it
we'd probably demolish Mercury entirely
before we moved on to Venus Mars and the
outer planets
even nearby asteroids would be decimated
however even just deconstructing Mercury
would Supply us with enough energy to
power up our supercomputers and boost
Interstellar exploration
maybe we'd even build Earth-like oases
large rotating space colonies in the
habitable zone of our solar system
maybe if we're lucky we'd find other
more efficient sources of energy to help
us Master space travel
one day we want to take Humanity into
space but
why don't we start small
take one solar power station 10 000
people and 10 million tons of crumbled
Moon Rock and you get a space habitat a
Stanford Taurus
how would this habitat work
who would be allowed to live there
and how would it help to reverse climate
change on Earth
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we built a Stanford Taurus
we've already hypothesized about living
on an O'Neill cylinder
a Dyson Sphere even a matrushka brain
how would this habitat be any different
for one it's size
a Stanford Taurus would be about 60
times smaller than an O'Neill cylinder
and it's much much smaller than a Dyson
Sphere
to build a Stanford Taurus we'd need to
mine the moon a little
the Moon is a perfect mining candidate
because it has oxygen in its rocks that
we could use to make a breathable
atmosphere and manufacture water
it has silica we'd use for Windows and
solar cells it also has aluminum that
would work perfectly for construction
but of course securing the materials is
only the beginning
we'd start assembling the habitat in
space between the Moon and the Earth
it would have to be close enough to the
moon so that we could easily transport
the materials
it would also need to be far enough from
the earth that it wouldn't fall into our
planet's orbit
our Stanford Taurus would look like a
bicycle wheel and the spokes would join
together at the center
the inhabitants would live in the tire
section
but before we bring people in
we need to create a proper environment
and life support
to imitate the Earth's gravity we'd make
the habitat complete a full spin on its
axis every minute
the centrifugal force would make up for
the weightlessness you normally
experience in space
because you don't want things to float
around
the habitat would get all its sunlight
beamed down by a large mirror stationed
directly over the Hub at a 45 degree
angle
it would direct solar rays into the
smaller mirrors on the outer shell of
the Taurus
those mirrors would also act as part of
The Shield from all the harmful Cosmic
radiation
living in this space habitat would be
like living in a small town
there would be no skyscrapers only Labs
high-tech farms and housing
most of the people living on the
Stanford tourists would be scientists or
Engineers Farmers or space construction
workers
they take up a permanent residence on
the Taurus with their families where
they would live a sustainable Colony
life
population of the Stanford tourists
would be limited to about 10 000 people
all the inhabitants would be strictly
selected through extensive tests and
training
but we wouldn't just build the habitat
for the sake of it
the Stanford tourists would benefit deep
space research and act as a maintenance
and construction point for satellite
solar power stations
the solar power stations would provide
for all the colonies energy needs and
would have the potential to supply
energy to Earth as well
we'd beam solar energy down with lasers
or microwave emitters then we would
collect that energy above the Earth's
atmosphere
having so much solar generated power we
wouldn't need to burn any fossil fuels
give it enough time and our planet might
just recover from climate change
but all that wouldn't be cheap
the cost of a Stanford tourist would
come to some 900 billion dollars
but we could minimize a large chunk of
that cost by using reusable SpaceX
Rockets to send people to space
eventually we'd start building more
habitats and explore more of the solar
system
we've built a lunar base and then set a
course for Mars
but before you sign up for that mission
you need to have a good survival
strategy in case something goes wrong
and we have a show for you that covers
just that to help you survive
whatever awaits it
global warming continues to get worse
it's destroying our land and killing our
people
but what if there was a way to stop it
almost instantly
we might not even need to sacrifice our
cars or change what we eat instead we
could build a shield to block out the
Sun
climate change
how possible is something like this
[Music]
and could this end up being a bad thing
for the Earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we built a sun shield in space
a sun shield would be like a massive
umbrella in space
it would divert Rays from the Sun
reducing heat and solar radiation on
Earth
[Music]
it's been proposed for decades by
scientists and could One Day become a
reality
but there's a couple of conditions
it would cost trillions of dollars in
every country on Earth would need to be
on board
easy right
well let's just assume this happens and
we'll just skip to the good stuff
the sun shield would be created by
sending small Flyers up into space
they would have incredibly thin mirrors
and would connect to make one massive
umbrella
it would be half the size of the Earth
and located one and a half million
kilometers away from the planet
at this location it would be the same
distance from the earth all year round
The Shield would block out just two
percent of the sun's rays which would
reduce the Earth's temperature by about
one degree
that was the Earth's temperature just
before the Industrial Revolution
as more flyers are added the sun shield
would change Earth's temperature
gradually
this is so we don't shock every living
species on Earth with a sudden
temperature change
as this happens tropical climates will
get colder and the Arctic will be able
to stay Frozen For the First Time in
decades
decreasing the Earth's temperature will
also affect the water cycle
we would have fewer heavy rainstorms
hurricanes and flooding
but if we got rid of climate change
would humans continue to act as they do
today
people and big Industries might still
release lots of carbon dioxide and
methane
since we'd have conquered global warming
humans might go ahead and create even
more greenhouse gases and then they'll
all get trapped in our atmosphere
but at least we wouldn't have to worry
about climate change right
well not quite it is possible that
something could go wrong with the sun
shield like getting hit by an asteroid
or drifting out of position
we'd have to adjust the shield every few
years and if we forgot to do that the
consequences would be devastating
if we didn't replace The Shield at the
end of its 50-year life cycle we'd be
hit by a global temperature change
faster than ever before
instead of the Earth's temperature
increasing over years or decades it
would happen within a couple of months
by up to three degrees
this increase in temperature would be a
huge shock to everything on Earth
including the planet itself
certain areas would become more prone to
droughts While others would have massive
floods
this would destroy our infrastructure
and cities
crops would also die and water would be
harder to obtain
Antarctica would be melting again while
drier areas would be burning with
wildfires
and with this happening so quickly
species wouldn't be able to adapt and
that includes us
millions of people could die and
hundreds of species could go extinct
and since people didn't decrease the
amount of carbon dioxide and methane we
released into our atmosphere when we had
the sun shield it would be too late at
this point
the Earth would continue to heat up
until our planet becomes an unlivable
desert
so having a sun shield shouldn't be seen
as a bandage for climate change
instead it should be looked at as a
possible Second Chance For Humanity to
make up for its mistakes
but due to the astronomical cost it's
unlikely a sunshield would even be built
do you ever question the nature of your
reality
are you real
or are you a product of some complex
computer simulation
what I'm about to tell you might change
the way you perceive the world
and it all starts with a cosmic Mega
structure the size of our solar system
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could build a matrushka
brain
we've talked about Cosmic Mega
structures before but this one isn't
like any other
to understand what a matrushka brain is
and how it could change your outlook on
life
we need to start from the beginning
Dyson Sphere
in 1960 a physicist and a Seeker for
alien life Freeman Dyson came up with
the idea that advanced extraterrestrial
civilizations would build space
megastructures around their host star
they do it to collect all of their
star's energy and fuel their travels
Across the Universe
or they'd simply use this structure as
real estate
location location location
then almost 50 years later an inventor
by the name of Robert Bradbury gave new
meaning to Dyson spheres
according to his calculations by the
year 2250 Humanity would become Advanced
enough to start building a megastructure
similar to the one proposed by Dyson but
instead of having just one sphere around
the Sun we'd stack them around one
another
just like the Russian matrushka dolls
what materials would we need to build a
structure like that how far into the
solar system would our construction
stretch
and most importantly what would we be
using this matrushka brain for
we'd start with a single Dyson Sphere
we'd use this first shell to draw the
energy from the Sun
a Dyson Sphere would give us so much
solar energy that it'd be enough to
power the most advanced computer in the
universe
I told you a matrushka brain isn't just
any megastructure we could live on
it's a giant supercomputer the size of
the solar system
the shells of the matrushka brain would
expand from the orbit of mercury beyond
the orbit of Neptune
they'd be passing energy from the Sun
down to the last outer shell
we'd have robots mine Venus for its
Rocky silicate mantle until there's
nothing left of it
but silicon isn't the only thing we'd
need for this Construction
the shells of the matrushka brain would
be made of a material called
computronium
it's a hypothetical material we've yet
to invent but the idea behind it is that
every particle would be a tiny computer
capable of passing computer codes to
other particles
the matrushka brain would start writing
its own code building itself and
expanding far into the solar system
it would be capable of calculating and
predicting every event from human
interactions to Cosmic occurrences
processing power would have no limits at
all
what would it mean for us to have
unlimited computing power
how would we use it
building a megastructure like this would
make us a type 2 civilization on the
kardashev scale
it's a scale that characterizes
civilizations by their energy disposal
level
a type 1 civilization is one that's
tamed all of its planets resources and
can control the weather earthquakes even
volcanoes
a type 2 civilization can Harvest all
the energy of its host star
with all the energy of the Sun at our
disposal we could become Intergalactic
Travelers
yeah we could leave our solar system and
go explore what's out there
we could relocate to other planets if we
wanted but most likely that's not where
we'd end up
with the computational power of the
matrushka brain we could simulate an
alternate digital reality
we could leave our physical bodies
behind and upload our brains into that
virtual world
we'd become a new species Immortal
entities with unlimited Computing
abilities
we'd create our own universes with our
own rules or maybe we'd recreate our
world and control every aspect of it
well that said how can you tell if you
aren't already inside a matrushka brain
right doesn't this make you question
your entire reality
before we get to the next episode let's
take another moment to tell you about
how we've been making our short form
content here at what if for the past
while we've been using this awesome
service called Opus clip let me show you
how it works all you have to do is
upload or link your own long form video
and then Opus clip magically takes the
best parts of your video and creates a
standalone short from it what's even
cooler well each video has its own viral
rating this is where the AI predicts how
well your video can perform Opus has a
bunch of new features as well from being
able to upload to social directly from
the site to manually reframing your
Clips so if you're a Creator who wants
to get into short form content Opus clip
is for you and the best part it's
totally free to try go to opus.pro to
check it out Link in the description
[Music]
tired of
lit at Earth why not move to the O'Neill
cylinder an artificial state-of-the-art
space habitat where we can control
everything including the weather
what would it take to build a space
station like this
how big would it be
and how would we make it suitable for
life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could build an O'Neill
cylinder
when physicist Gerald k O'Neal came up
with the idea of his space colony in
1974. people thought he was crazy
back then a cylinder floating in space
didn't seem like a space habitat anyone
would want to move to
but fast forward to our time
the world is grown by 4 billion people
climate change is on the rise
moving to a space station doesn't seem
so crazy anymore huh
now this far-fetched idea inspires
wealthy dreamers like Jeff Bezos who is
looking into building enough O'Neill
cylinders to board one trillion people
but how exactly would this work
the idea behind the O'Neill cylinder
space station is simple it would be a
rotating space station about six and a
half kilometers in diameter and 26
kilometers in length
to build a structure that size we
wouldn't need to collapse all the
planets in the solar system like we
would for some of the other space
megastructures
mining our moon and some nearby
asteroids should be enough to provide us
with all the materials we'd need
we'd assembled the cylindrical station
right in space somewhere between the
Earth and the Moon
we'd Park the O'Neill cylinder at a
LaGrange point where it would stay in
place without being drawn into the orbit
of either the Earth or the Moon
instructing the O'Neill cylinder would
be one thing but we'd also need to make
it habitable
that means giving it gravity water and a
breathable atmosphere
gravity would be easy the cylinder would
make a full rotation in two minutes
that would generate a centripetal force
which we would experience as gravity
to make the structure more stable and
prevent it from drifting away we'd need
to build two counter rotating cylinders
connected at each end
we designed the space Habitat to mimic
Earth's air pressure at sea level and
the built-in aluminum mirrors would give
us control over the amount of sunlight
getting inside the habitat
we'd be able to set our own day and
night cycle and manage the temperature
inside the O'Neill cylinder too
this space habitat would be powered by
solar energy gathered by all the solar
panels covering the outer cylinder
we'd create artificial mountains valleys
and forests
we'd bring in water derived from Icy
comets
to get around the cylinder we'd use
cable cars or you could simply ride a
bike
[Music]
it would be like a mini Earth but with
us having complete control over its
climate
[Music]
all that would take six years and a few
trillion dollars to build
and if you don't want to give up your
home on Earth for some space habitat the
O'Neill cylinder would make a great
vacation spot
welcome to O'Neill cylinder one where
there's no gloomy weather and where all
your food is grown at a local Farm climb
up our artificial mountain and enjoy a
great view from our space habitat for
the low low price
of course there would be some challenges
we'd have to get really good at
recycling all the waste aboard the space
habitat or it would quickly turn into a
space garbage bin
then there are the asteroids
we'd have to keep track of how much
damage they cause when they hit the
O'Neill cylinder so that the situation
doesn't get out of hand
and if something went wrong on the
O'Neill cylinder we could always use our
plan B
Mars might be a harsh place to move to
but we've got some tips for you on how
to survive the red planet
check out our new show that will help
you survive whatever awaits you
what if someday we decided that the
usefulness of our planet had run its
course and humans needed to scour space
to find somewhere new to live
but instead of finding a potentially
habitable Earth-like exoplanet light
years away we'd build our own artificial
world right here in the solar system
what kind of Technology would we need to
manufacture a new planet where would we
find enough raw materials for our future
world and how long would it take us to
finish this planetary construction
project
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we built an artificial planet
rocky planets like Earth are born from
the leftover material of a newly formed
star
they start off as grains of dust smaller
than the width of a human hair
these grains fuse into larger chunks
that keep colliding with each other
until after a few million years they
develop into a new terrestrial world
theoretically we understand how planets
are formed in the universe but how would
we go about manufacturing an artificial
one
if we humans were to build a planetary
replica and populate it we'd have to
churn out a rock with an atmosphere of
breathable air the right temperature
Earth-like gravity and a stable orbit
around the Sun and that's just for
starters
we'd start the construction in the Sun's
habitable zone
that would help us maintain Earth-like
temperatures on our artificial Planet
but where would we find all the
materials to build it
asteroids might seem like a good source
the problem is the Earth has the mass of
over 2 000 asteroid belts
there's simply not enough asteroids in
the solar system to build a new
earth-sized world
but there could be enough materials in
the Oort cloud the swarm of icy debris
that hypothetically exists in the
outermost reaches of the solar system
but this cloud is so far away that even
Voyager 1 that's been traveling at 17
kilometers per second for the past 41
years won't reach it for another 300
years
and it won't make it to the other side
of the Oort Cloud for about 30 000 years
we'd need to build some faster
spacecraft to get all that dust and
nudge it in the right direction
we could also start stealing moons from
other planets all of Jupiter's moons for
example would give us enough material to
craft a planet about seven percent the
size of Earth
that would be a good start if we could
manage to pull them out of Jupiter's
orbit
it wouldn't be necessary to build our
new world as big as the Earth to
replicate the same force of gravity we
feel now if we could pack one tenth of
the Earth's mass into a sphere the size
of the Moon it would do the same trick
still it would take us at least several
hundred years to finish the construction
once all the engineering issues were
solved and our newly formed artificial
Planet settled into orbit around the sun
we dump in some water
we'd let it evaporate to create the
atmosphere we could even inject some of
the carbon dioxide released by polluting
Industries on Earth
then we bring in the plants plants would
slowly build up oxygen in the atmosphere
through photosynthesis
finally after Millennia of Planet
building the first human colonies would
set foot on the new terrestrial
human-made planet
even though it would be smaller in size
the Earth's replica wouldn't seem much
different from the original
Earth-like temperatures and gravity
would make it feel like our home planet
but it wouldn't be as stable as the
Earth our artificial world would require
active maintenance from the planetary
environment to our orbital parameters
currently there's so much we don't know
about the universe and we can only guess
how a new planet would form within it at
this point it may be easier to terraform
an existing World instead of building a
totally new one
are you ready for the trip of a lifetime
because this not so little machine is
about to take you on one
a trip back in time
what would you need for this time travel
to happen
how would it mess with your body
and what do black holes have to do with
all this
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you built a tipler time
machine
theoretically building a time traveling
device is possible or almost possible
all you'd need to do is to assemble an
enormous cylinder and get yourself a
spaceship then you'd need to figure out
how to make the cylinder spin at a few
billion rotations per minute
and remember when I said it was enormous
well for this cylinder to work its
length would need to be infinite
before I get into the explanation of how
this time machine works let me give you
a bit of a backstory
in 1915 Albert Einstein came up with his
theory of general relativity
he claimed that our universe can be
described by four dimensions
the first three would be the dimensions
of space and the fourth would be time
together there's space time
gravity can bend space-time like a
bowling ball would bend a rubber sheet
the bending of space-time makes time
[Music]
the passage of time also changes
depending on how fast you move
the theory of general relativity blew
people's minds but in 1974 Frank tippler
realized that solutions to equations of
general relativity could be used to
build a time traveling device
[Music]
now that you're all caught up let's
start building this machine already
first you'd need to find material with
the total mass of about 10 Suns
where you'd find all that matter is a
big question of course but let's assume
you managed to strip all the neighboring
star systems and assemble them into a
cylinder somewhere above the Earth
ten solar masses worth of matter is no
joke it would take up a lot of space and
you would have to figure out how to
compress all that matter
it would have to be so dense that it
would turn into an elongated black hole
there's no time to worry about getting
sucked into it now that you've finally
assembled a tipler cylinder you'd need
to make it rotate at an unimaginably
fast rate a few billion times every
minute
theoretically instead of condensing a
whole lot of matter into a black hole
and then having to deal with the
cylinder rotation you could just find a
few neutron stars
those are leftovers from gigantic stars
that didn't have enough Mass to collapse
into black holes
and they rotate pretty fast you could
line a few of them up and synchronize
their rotation
but even if you chose the fastest ones
their rotation wouldn't come close to a
few billion times per minute
besides we did an earlier video about
trying to bring a spoonful of neutron
star back to Earth and it didn't go that
well
anyway regardless of how you achieve
this effect the massive gravitational
pull of the cylinder combined with the
fast rotation would create a frame
dragging effect
in other words the cylinder would drag
space-time along with it that means that
you could hop on a spacecraft and follow
the spiral course of the cylinder and
that would take you back in time
would fold upon itself and you'd find
yourself in a closed time-like curve
it's a loop in which you're traveling
into the past has always been a part of
that past so you wouldn't create any
time paradoxes
if you change the direction of your
travel you go back to the future or
rather back to the time you started your
journey from
the tipler cylinder specialty is travel
into the past not the future but hey you
could hang out with your favorite people
from the past go see a real life
Jurassic world you could even go back to
the time when the earth didn't have any
life at all
but of course there is a drawback all
that would only be possible if the
tipler cylinder had an infinite length
it would have to go on forever
but that's just impossible you can't
build something that has no end at all
if you try to make a finite cylinder
then you'd have to deal with some exotic
matter and it's negative energy
but we haven't discovered it yet and it
doesn't look like we'll be getting our
hands on this kind of matter anytime
soon
I haven't even mentioned the effects of
the black hole on your body
you'd instantly get sucked into the
cylinder's black hole if you got close
enough
but hopefully there are other ways that
would allow you to travel through time
and when you do we'll be there for you
and help you survive this kind of trip
on our new show how to survive
all right
this is not some DVD floating in space
it's a mega structure that might One Day
become Humanity's home
[Music]
the Earth might not remain how